bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition d'Europe Hebdo nous sommes au
cœur du Parlement européen à Strasbourg
oui Katia et dans cette édition
direction la Pologne c'est un des
premiers pays européens à exploiter ses
gaz de schiste et ici au Parlement le
débat ferrage mais d'abord l'actualité
dominée par la situation à Gaza et en
Israël que fait l'Union européenne pour
le proche orient c'est la question de la
semaine à Gaza les années se suivent et
se ressemblent 2008 plomb d'urc 2012
pilier de la défense Israël contre Hamas
bombe contre roquette sécurité contre
survie et comme toujours à la clé des
centaines de morts dont des femmes et
des enfants
c'est aussi l'éternel retour du balai
diplomatique les délégations se suivent
et se ressemblent aussi Égypte ONU
France Turquie Qatar objectif obtenir
une trêve un cesser le feu stopper cette
fameuse escalade de la
violence pendant ce temps en Europe face
à l'urgence on se réunit et surprise on
accouche d'un communiqué dans lequel
l'Union demande un immédiat un peu court
non alors que fait l'union pour le
Proche
Orient et la violence redouble au Proche
Orient ce mercredi 21 novembre nouvel
attentat en plein cœur de telavive une
actualité internationale chargée pour en
parler un député européen est avec nous
Arnaud danjan bonjour alors vous êtes
membre du Parti populaire européen vous
siégez à la commission des affaires
étrangères et vous êtes responsable vous
vous êtes rapporteur sur la politique de
défense européenne donc vous connaissez
bien cette ces questions est-ce que
selon vous l'Europe peut faire quelque
chose face à l'escalade au Proche Orient
ou est-ce que au contraire elle est
totalement impuissante non l'Europe est
pas totalement impuissante et et c'est
un peu un raccourci de dire que l'Europe
ne peut faire que des communiqués c'est
la version effectivement visible
immédiate de de l'action un peu modeste
mais diplomatiquement il y a quand même
beaucoup de de négociation en cou et
quand on mentionne les visites de tel ou
tel ministre des Affaires étrangères
d'un pays européen son action est
coordonnée avec celle de la Haute
Représentante Kathy Ashton elle est
coordonnée avec celle des 26 autres pays
donc il y a une activité diplomatique
intense c'est vrai que pour le grand
public tout ça n'est n'est pas très
spectaculaire tout ça ne se voit pas
beaucoup et on a l'impression d'une
impuissance générale mais l'Europe
j'allais dire n'est pas plus impuissante
que malheureusement d'autres acteurs qui
essayent aussi eux de mettre un terme à
cette escalade de la violence mais
concrètement vous êtes député européen
le le Parlement européen condamne les
les violences dans une résolution mais
est-ce que à part condamner regretter il
n'y a pas quelque chose de de de plus à
faire en utilisant notamment par exemple
les des des sanctions ou économiques ou
un moy d'tion économ vous
savez l'Europe a une action économique
assez forte dans la région au Proche
Orient auprès de l'Autorité
palestinienne la situation de Gaza est
mal mal heureusement très spécifique
puisque c'est une enclave tenue par le
Hamas avec lequel les relations sont
impossibles du fait des position extrême
que tient le Hamas vis-à-vis d'Israël et
ensuite vous avez effectivement cet
escalade de la violence dont on espère
qu'elle sera ponctuelle mais qui est
toujours trop
évidemment l'Europe a tenté de faire des
choses l'Europe avait par exemple monté
une mission pour le point frontière
entre l'Égypte et Gaza pour essayer de
contrôler les biens qui transitent par
ces s points frontières donc vous savez
que les Israéliens sont sont très sont
très sensibles puisque beaucoup d'armes
ont transité aussi cette mission n'est
plus possible dans le dans le contexte
actuel mais pourquoi pas un jour ou
l'autre l'Europe comme facilitateur
d'échanges commerciaux pour subvenir au
besoins de la population par exemple
donc ce sont évidemment des exemples
très modestes mais l'Europe est déjà
présente elle pourrait sans doute l'être
un peu plus ça dépend aussi de la
volonté des deux partis et en
l'occurrence je ne suis pas certain que
les deux partis soient forcément très
désireuse d'avoir l'Europe comme un
interlocuteur un peu plus un peu plus
puissant sur place il y a un
représentant qui travaille au côté de
Madame Ashton est-ce que lui qu'est-ce
qu'il fait sur place en fait saz
l'équation l'équation du conflit
israëlo-palestinien elle est à la fois
très simple et et quasi insoluble tous
les paramètres sont sur la table on sait
très bien queles sont les les les choses
qui bloquent pour parvenir à des accords
mais personne n'a la baguette magique
pour débloquer ces choses-là euh alors
évidemment tout ça est extrêmement
frustrant mais je crois qu'il faut pas
pour autant minimiser les efforts qui
sont qui sont qui sont faits encore une
fois les résultats sont pas forcément
spectaculaires on ne peut pas non plus
se substituer au parties elle-même on
peut les inciter on peut les encourager
on peut les sanctionner le cas échéant
mais on peut pas substituer au parti
elle-même l'idée d'une force
d'interposition avait été évoqué est-ce
que ça pourrait être une solution selon
vous c'est un sujet qui revient
régulièrement pour avoir une force
d'interposition il faut d'abord l'accord
des deux parties c'est là encore où on
revient toujours à ce même problème il
faut l'accord des deux parties et puis
il faut avoir des pays qui sont prêt à
contribuer or compte tenu de la
complexité de la situation de la
dangerosité de la situation vous savez
on a déjà des forces d'interposition au
Sud Liban on pourrait un jour envisager
d'en avoir entre une Autorité
palestinienne ou Gaza même et les
Israéliens elles peuvent être efficaces
parfois ces forces on l'a vu dans
certains P oui elles peuvent être
efficaces mais leur efficacité dépend
aussi beaucoup de la bonne volonté des
deux parties de de jouer le jeu je suis
pas sûr que ce paramètre existe
actuellement entre Israël et la
Palestine alors il y a la situation au
ProcheOrient il y a aussi la situation
en Syrie au Congo au Mali est-ce que sur
tous ces théâtres de conflits l'Europe
peut faire quelque chose et parlons
notamment du du Mali il y a un otage
français qui a été fait au un otage
français au Mali est-ce que le ce
contexte de durcissement rend toujours
possible une éventuelle intervention
européenne sur ce théâtre là oui et
d'ailleurs l'Europe a pris des décisions
là encore sans doute des décisions qui
apparaîtront trop modestes et et
peut-être un peu tardives mais en tout
cas l'Europe a pris des décisions celle
d'envoyer une mission de formation
auprès des forces de sécurité maliennes
dont on sait qu'elles seront en première
position si une intervention militaire a
lieu la position européenne est assez
claire si intervention militaire il y a
elle doit être conduite par des africain
mais avec un soutien européen c'est un
soutien qui peut-être logistique un
soutien en formation c'est ce que
l'Union européenne a décidé donc c'est
quelque chose qui va se mettre en en
place on peut regretter et je l'ai fait
à titre au titre de la sous-commission
de la défense du Parlement européen on
peut regretter que ça intervienne sans
doute un peu tard vous savez que l'Union
européenne avait pensé réfléchi à cette
stratégie sur le Sahel depuis longtemps
depuis mars avril 2011 des conclusions
avaient été faites au niveau du Conseil
européen malheureusement nous les
mettons en œuvre que maintenant un an et
demi après c'est un peu long mais le
fait qu'il y a un otage français au Mali
ça ne remet pas en cause toutes les tous
ces préparatifs
pas la donne le fait qu'il y a des
otages français puisque avec le nouvel
otage dont on a appris récemment la la
capture ça ça fait maintenant h otages
français évidemment évidment évidemment
ça complique les choses évidemment ça
peut inhiber par rapport à des
interventions militaires mais encore une
fois j'allais dire le processus est en
marche mais le processus est en marche
aussi avec une médiation diplomatique si
on arrive à trouver une solution
politique et il faudra bien de toute
façon un accord politique avant ou après
une intervention militaire euh on privil
privilégiera pardon cette option là mais
il faut être prêt à toute éventualité
euh vous dites que le on aurait pu aller
plus vite sur ce front-l vous vous le
regrettezoui oui je regrette beaucoup
parce que les éléments étaient connus
depuis longtemps on sait que cette zone
du Sahel est une zone instable
malheureusement tous les États européens
ne sont pas sensibilisés de la même
façon ça paraît une évidence pour nous
Français qui sommes confrontés au
problème des otages euh c'est beaucoup
moins évident quand vous êtes polonais
balte slovaque de considérer que le Mali
est une priorité stratégique pour
l'Union européenne et donc c'est ce
travail de conviction qui a pris
beaucoup de temps auprès de tous nos
partenaires et pour vous c'est une
priorité stratégique pour moi c'est une
priorité parce qu' se passe dans le
Sahel au-delà même du Mali il se passe
dans cette région du Sahel qui est très
proche euh il se passe si vous voulez la
euh la synthèse de du terrorisme de la
criminalité organisée des problèmes
migratoires des problèmes de
développement c'est donc une zone
explosive alors la sécurité n'est pas la
seule réponse mais en tout cas sans
sécurité on ne pourra pas avoir des
politiques de développement efficaces
dans cette région alors une dernière
question peut-être sur la Syrie est-ce
que vous pensez que l'Union européenne
peut et doit reconnaître l'opposition
syrienne qui vient tout juste de se
constituer alors l'Union européenne a en
début de semaine franchi un premier pas
en considérant en considérant que la la
nouvelle coalition nationale syrienne
est une voix
légitime et contrairement à la France et
à l'Angleterre l'Union européenne dans
sa globalité n'a pas reconnu comme la
seule autorité légitime ce nouveau
conseil cette nouvelle coalition
nationale euh c'est une question
extrêmement compliquée euh il faut se
méfier quand même on a quand même
affaire à à une coalition qui est très
hétéroclite la représentativité la
représentativité est quand même encore
mal établie on n'est pas exactement dans
la même configuration que la Libye c'est
un cas la Syrie est un cas beaucoup plus
compliqué que que la que la Libye et
c'est ce qui ce qui rend évidemment
toute solution là aussi beaucoup plus
aléatoire merci merci beaucoup Arnaud
danjan d'avoir été avec nous alors
l'actualité c'est aussi la bataille du
budget européen qui bat son plein un
pays s'illustre le Royaume-Uni qui
refuse d'augmenter sa contribution à ce
budget du coup les médias européens
s'interrogent les Britanniques ont-ils
toujours leur place dans l'Union
européenne réponse avec ce tour
d'horizon des télé européennes signé
Aurélie
dafas une Europe à 26 sans la
Grande-Bretagne
ch dans les années 70 la Grande-Bretagne
votait massivement pour rejoindre la
communauté européenne 36 ans plus tard
les journaux et les politiciens
conservateurs appellent un référendum
sur l'adhésion à l'UE la crise est pour
quelque chose certainement mais pour
beaucoup les médias sont à blamés une
position séparatiste portée par les
libéraux-démocrates et qui agace en
Allemagne qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent les
Britanniques alors ce n'est pas si
difficile à comprendre ils veulent tous
les avantages sans les désavantages
aujourd'hui plus que jamais il n'y a pas
d'Européen convaincu à Londres et l'un
d'entre eux est le Libéral Démocrate
Nickle quand vous invitez quelqu'un à
dîner il y a toujours la bonne vieille
question de qui P l'addition quand David
a reçu Angela ce soir au 10 Downing
Street la question de l'addition àortée
sur le budget de l'Union européenne pour
6 ans 3000 milliards d'euros à quelques
centimes
près et avec nous Christophe Garche
rédacteur en chef d'europal tv tv même
en français merci d'être avec nous alors
comment vous comprenez cette attitude de
Londres et surtout est-ce que vous
pensez que les Britanniques ont encore
toujours leur place en Europe première
chose sur le budget tous les
étatsmembres dans l'Union connaissent
une crise sans précédent restriction
budgétaire vérité est-ce qu'on peut
entendre le message d'un chef d'État qui
dit ou d'un chef de gouvernement qui
disent écoutez moi j'ai des problèmes
dans mon pays je suis obligé de couper
les budgets partout vous pouvez pas me
demander d'augmenter le budget européen
il faut qu'il y ait une une
interconnexion enfin sinon les gens mes
électeurs vont pas comprendre ça c'est
la vision sans doute qu'on peut et qu'on
doit entendre mais la vérité c'est que
le budget de l'Europe c'est pas un
budget de dépenses inutile c'est un
budget globalement d'investissement pour
quoi pour pour la pour l'avenir pour les
les les les pour les réseaux
d'infrastructure pour la aider les les
les régions en retard de développement à
se développer donc il faut entendre ces
deux messages et puis dernier argument
c'est sûr c'est la crise aujourd'hui
mais ce qu'on doit geler pour les 10
prochaines années un le budget européen
parce que c'est la crise on sait pas ce
qui va se passer dans 3 ans on espère
que d'ici 3 ans on en sortira donc voilà
c'est tout ça qu'il faut faire entendre
et visiblement le message ne passe pas à
londr c'est tout simple alors les
Britanniques l'attitud des britannique
agace de plus en plus de nombreux pays
européens l'Allemagne même la
France à en croire les dernières
déclarations de de François Hollande qui
a critiqué l'attitude de Londres qui
s'accroche à son Rabé c'est ce qu'il a
dit en substance et du coup on parle de
plus en plus du Brit du brexit le Brit
existe ça veut dire mettre la
Grande-Bretagne dehors en dehors de
l'Union Européenne est-ce que c'est
réaliste ou c'est complètement les
traités aujourd'hui les traités
européens le permettent le nouveau
traité de Lisbonne qu'on a eu tant de
mal à faire adopter permet aujourd'hui
la sécession un État membre n'est plus
point piisé point lié à vitam etnam en
Europe s'il le veut quand il le veut ça
il peut demander à sortir de l'Union
soit les Britanniques pourraient d'ici
2015 demander ce droit revendiquer ce
droit à sortir de l'Union européenne et
à renégocier son avenir avec les
européens ou sans les Européens et ben
on en reparlera dans quelques temps
merci beaucoup Christophe Garche on
poursuit avec un focus sur les gaz de
schiste nous sommes allés voir comment
ça se passer en Pologne pays où le
nombre de permis d'exploitation pour le
gaz de schist augmente mais la
contestation elle aussi grossit regardez
ce reportage tourné près de Varsovie par
Paul
Bouffard cette eau minéral a beaucoup de
vertus curatives elle est utilisée
depuis des siècles pour guérir de
nombreux mots en danger à cause des
forages effectués dans la région pour
trouver du gaz de chiste Robert ne se
prive pas de goûter l'eau de son village
une eau minéral réputé en Pologne et
pourtant la source est en surci à cause
de l'exploitation du gaz de schiste
d'ici quelques mois dans la région des
forages devrai voir le jour un drame
pour Robert son projet de rénover les
termes tomberait à
l'eau personne n'investira si des
forrages pour extraire le gaz de schiste
se fond dans un rayon de 10 km
il y aura danger de pollution pour les
Alines le gaz de schiste son
exploitation nécessite une fracturation
hydraulique les compagnies gazières
injectent sous pression un grand volume
d'eau mêlé à des produits chimiques dans
la terre la roche explose et libère le
gaz prisonnier les résidus d'eau peuvent
contaminer les napes fréatique voisine
et pour l'État polonais impossible de
passer à côté de cette nouvelle source
d'énergie
le gouvernement défend son nouvel
eldorado le gaz de chist c'est une
chance pour la Pologne mais aussi pour
l'Union européenne cette forme d'énergie
peut jouer un rôle important pour la
relance de l'économie polonaise mais
aussi rendre la Pologne indépendante
vis-à-vis des étrangers le gouvernement
espère profiter des réserves importantes
du pays pour alimenter en gaz sa
population pendant plusieurs dizaines
d'années sans avoir besoin de son voisin
russe jusqu 2022 la Pologne est liée par
contrat avec le géant russe de l'énergie
Gazprom qui leur fournit près de la
moitié de leur consommation gazière le
gaz de schiste pourrait inverser la
tendance nous considérons avec beaucoup
de rigueur les angoisses des populations
et nous voulons lutter contre les mythes
liés au gaz de
schiste par exemple mon ministre le
ministre du Trésor a bu en direct à la
télévision nationale le liquide que l'on
injecte pour la fracturation pour
prouver que ce n'est pas du poison
barsovie compte investir plus de 12
milliards d'euros dans l'exploitation de
ce gaz de schiste alors on ouvre les
portes à tous les investisseurs et dans
les campagnes polonaises on installe les
forages comme ici à garvoline à 2h de
route de la capitale selon la compagnie
polonaise d'énergie Orlen qui n'a pas
souhaité nous ouvrir officiellement les
portes du site il n'y a aucun danger les
rejets polluants passeront dans un
système
d'épuration
onaise ilce cette expitation du solel
lui le gouvernement a trop vite oublié
l'impact
écologique il y aura des centaines puis
des milliers de forage comme celui-ci
car pour le gaz deiste on a besoin de
beaucoup plus de forage que dans le cas
du gaz
naturel hab son le voisin
pourourisme véritable
danger alors il y a du gaz le forage va
s'installer pas de
commentaire ah c'est intéressant ça vous
n'avez rien trouvé
donc cet engouement pour le gaz de
schiste est né d'une étude d'expert
selon le Département américain de
l'énergie la Pologne serait assise sur
5300 milliards de m de gaz soit 300 ans
d'indépendance gazière mais pour
expert indépendant la réalité est moins
rose les Américains ont surévalué la
richesse le gaz de schiste pour
l'instant Pologne c'est quelque chose de
de virtuel de très virtuel c'est c'est
avant tout une affaire politique mais
pour l'instant il faut bien dire que
rien n'est rentable regardez sur 31
forages effectués actuellement il n en a
aucun qui est véritablement exploitable
alors le gaz de schiste en Pologne on ne
peut pas encore vraiment estimer son
coût d'exploitation peut-être
dollar pour 1000 m c'est en tout cas en
tout cas ça reste fois plus cher que le
gaz
naturelaroline rencontre les voisins du
forage et chez les agriculteurs
l'inquiétude montez faire sil expit près
de vos champ est déjà
sal c'est
vrai elle est
comment alors vous la
buz
MP
in allez brune depuis quand depuis
qu'ils ont commencé à
forer je sais pas ce que nous allons
devenir relancer l'économie se défaire
de la main russe selon un sondage 73 %
des Polonais disent oui au gaz de
schiste et pour s'assurer le succès le
gouvernement distribue les permis
d'exploitation pour quelques dizaines de
milliers de dollars y compris sur des
sites naturels protégés aucune règle
n'encadre installation de forage sur le
sol
polonais et voilà pour ce reportage
édifiant signé Paul Bouffard et
entre-temps sur ce plateau nous a
rejoint José Bovet merci d'être avec
nous on ne vous présente plus vous êtes
à la vice enfin vous détenez la
vice-présidence pardon de la Commission
sur l'agriculture et le développement
rural vous connaissez bien la Pologne et
la question des gaz de schist vous y
vous y êtes rendu plusieurs fois vous
connaissez Marek notamment qui est dans
ce
reportage ce mer mercredi le moratoire
que vous demandiez sur le gaz de schiste
a été rejeté au Parlement européen on
voit en Pologne que la contestation est
embryonnaire finalement est-ce que vous
avez perdu cette bataille ah écoutez non
je pense que pour l'instant quand on
réfléchit cette bataille elle a commencé
en France qui était un des premiers pays
européens où le combat est né en
décembre 2010 aujourd'hui on est en
novembre 2012 donc moins de 2 ans après
plusieurs pays ont déjà mis des
moratoires ont interdit la mauvaise la
technique de la fracturation hydraulique
qui est dangereuse celle qui peut risque
de polluer l'eau et cetera donc là c'est
déjà quelque chose d'extraordinaire et
on a un débat un premier débat sur une
initiative parlementaire donc en gros un
vœu ce qu'on a débattu aujourd'hui au
Parlement européen c'est un vœu donc il
y a eu un vœu sur les questions
environnementales nous on voulait qu'on
aille plus loin dans ce vu qu'on aille
jusqu'au matoire ça n'a pas été accepté
mais dans ce premier texte l'ensemble
des problèmes posés par le giste on ont
été bien montré démontré à partir de là
ce que j'espère c'est que la Commission
européenne elle va se saisir des
demandes du Parlement européen pour
mettre en cohérence la législation
européenne avec la question du gaz de
schiste donc vous voulez une législation
carrément sur la question alors il y
aura pas une législation parce qu'il
faut savoir qu'au niveau européen
l'énergie n'est pas une compétence
européenne ça reste de la compétence des
États voà chaque État fait ce qu'il veut
je dirais par fois ça peut être bien
parfois et souvent ça peut être
catastrophique la France avec le
nucléaire la Pologne avec le gaz de
schye pour faire un résumé
rapide par contre l'Union européenne a
des directives sur l'environnement il y
a une loi cadre sur l'eau qui permet de
savoir effectivement de protéger les NAF
réatiques mais aussi de savoir comment
on doit traiter l'eau qui remonte de la
fracturation hydraulique avec les
produits chimiques pour l'instant cette
eau n'a pas de statut est-ce que c'est
un déchet est-ce que c'est l'eau là il
va bien falloir qu'on lui donne un
statut comment on protège l'eau qui peut
être menacé par les fourrages quel est
le statut des produits chimiques
aujourd'hui qui sont mis dans la
fracturation parce que les entreprises
ne les ont jamais déclaré dans le cadre
de la directive rich sur les produits
chimiques comme rentrant dans un
processus minier donc là encore il va
falloir qu'il y ait une adaptation en
gros on ne peut pas faire de législation
globale mais on peut agir sur des des
des des petits bouts en fait de la
politique c'est ça que vous êtes en
train de nous dire effectivement il faut
que puisque c'est une nouvelle
technologie qui se met en place que la
législation européenne dans ses
différentes formes puisse effectivement
être adapté et puisse contrôler alors
justement à ce propos nous voyons dans
le reportage cette ce jeune homme qui
essaie de mettre en place des termes il
a une question à vous poser on
l'écoute
monsieur monsieur Bovet je suis très
inquiet en ce qui concerne le gaz de
chiste dans mon pays
par je trouve que le débat en France est
trs positif et que les solution à
questiont trs
Bonce que vous pvez expli àell et
europlementaires polonis en qui consiste
la loi
française il faut vraim tout faire pour
que cette soliqué en
polne prawodawstwa
polskiego quel moyens vous avez on vous
interpelle là directement quel moyen
vous avez d'agir sur ces questions et de
dupliquer pourquoi pas le modèle
français à
l'étranger le premier moyen c'est déjà
d'arriver à interpeller la commission
pour obliger la commission d'abord elle
a fait une étude ce qui est remarquable
on a eu deux études sur les risques
environnementaux liés à la fracturation
hydraulique et au gaz de chiste donc ça
la Commission a fait ce travail déjà
maintenant il faut qu'elle aille plus
loin la question de la fracturation
hydraulique reste un problème il y a pas
de technique altern native donc
effectivement c'est il existe de la
recherche et du développement il y a des
il y a des projets qui sont financés le
rapport Gallois d'ailleurs qui prévoit
de pourquoi pas enfin de ne pas du coup
mettre de côté la question du gaz de
schiste disait il faut quand même
essayer de trouver une solution pour
explorer cette cette voie là maisà il y
a des solutions ou pas pour l'instant il
y a aucune solution à 10 ans 15 ans
peut-être il y aura une solution donc ça
c'est un des vrais premiers problèmes
deuxième problème qui est lié à l'Europe
c'est que aujourd'hui
l'Europe s'est engagé dans le cadre du
programme 2020 dans le jargon européen à
réduire de 30 % ses émissions de CO2 par
rapport au réchauffement climatique or
on sait aujourd'hui que le méthane qui
est un qui est le gaz qui sort donc des
des puits de fracturation hydratique et
30 fois plus dangereux pour la planète
en terme de réchauffement c'est qu'il
est 30 fois plus efficace pour
ééchauffer la planète que le CO2 donc là
on a un vrai problème donc aujourd'hui
la question principale c'est comment
va-t-on faire parce que le la Banque
mondiale vient d'annoncer dimanche 18
novembre que si ça continuait c'est plus
4 degrés d'ici 2060 qu'on va atteindre
donc on a à la fois les questions
techniques les questions
environnementale et la question
climatique pour l'ensemble de ces
raisons il faut arrêter c'est pour ça
qu'on demande mais est-ce qu'on a les
moyens José Bovet d'arrêter ça on est
quand même dans une période où
l'indépendance énergétique est une
question cruciale on voudrait sortir du
nucléaire mais on a pas les moyens la
transition énergétique coûte extrêmement
cher est-ce qu'on a les moyens
objectivement de se passer d'une
ressource comme le gaz de schist les
États-Unis sont aujourd'hui indépendants
alors aujourd'hui on nous annonce une
indépendance pour les États-Unis j'ai
envie de dire pour combien d'années et à
quel coût environnemental mais même
social parce que je ne suis pas sûr que
ça va durer et là j'ai l'impression
qu'on est dans une bulle spéculative
d'ailleurs les ressources qui restent en
Pologne nous avvez annoncé effectivement
5000 trilliards on en est à 700
aujourd'hui réel ement a priori
potentiel avec un coût extraordinaire
aux États-Unis on n'est pas du tout dans
les mêmes couches géologiques on est
beaucoup plus haut donc ça coûte moins
cher à exploiter mais même pour cela je
suis pas sûr que ça va durer plus de 10
ou 15 ans donc je suis pas sûr que c'est
une quelque chose sur le long terme qui
va fonctionner deuxième problème c'est
que si on investit là on ninvestit pas
sur le renouvelable ça veut dire qu'on
n'enclenche pas dès aujourd'hui la
reconversion énergétique or ce que dit
le GC et ce que reprend aussi la B sur
le climat groupement sur le climat est
que reprend la Banque mondiale c'est
qu'il faut que le pic de la pollution
des émissions de CO2 soit atteint en
2020 et Cap 2020 on régresse pour ne pas
franchir la barre des 2 degrés
d'augmentation de la température sans
quoi on va vers des catastrophes donc il
faut savoir si on est capable de faire
ce saut et c'est pour ça que dans le
cadre des financements européens on dit
il faut lancer un grand programme
énergétique mais transversal entre les
pays pas simplement par pays par pays
pour interconnecter évidemment les
réseaux mais pour produire du
renouvelable et surtout pour aller
lutter contre le gaspillage dernière
question José Bovet rapidement est-ce
que si on trouve un moyen demain
d'extraire le gaz de chiste de manière
propre est-ce que vous dites banco on y
va non je dirais non parce que en raison
des émissions de méthane on n'est pas
capable de maîtriser le méthane qui sort
entre 4 et 8 % du méthane qui sort d'un
puit part dans l'atmosphère quoi qu'on
fasse donc réchauffe réchauffe
l'atmosphère et je crois que là
véritablement aujourd'hui il faut dire
STOP ça devient un enjeu mondial merci
José Bovet pour ses explications nous on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine à
Bruxelles d'ici là bonne suite de
programme sur les chaînes
parlementaires